M it's
God it's
God okay Mark 10:1 17 listen carefully
so the rich young man he runs up to
Jesus he gives him a title of Honor he
says to him good teacher what must I do
to get eternal life Jesus pounces on him
for calling him good teacher and say why
do you call me good there's no one good
except for only God alone and then Jesus
goes into the Preamble of advising him
what to do by keeping the Commandments
um and then the young man says teacher I
have kept these Commandments since I was
a Bo what do we notice in that response
the young man has dropped the title good
simply call Jesus teacher hence he has
understood the only God is good alone
very significant so what we have there
is a real what you call Powerhouse verse
which shows that the title of goodness
has been deferred to God Alone by Jesus
exclusively the young man has understood
that in the cont text because in verse
20 he drops the title good and simply
calls Jesus teacher hence he has
understood the only God is good alone I
want to just want me to deal with that
yeah I want you to deal with Mark 10:17
Okay cool
so uh the common misconception with
dealing with u Mark
10:17 is it seems like you're coming
from the perspective that Jesus is
denying to be good right and so you're
saying Jesus denies being good and says
that only God is good in the grand
scheme of things yes not that he's not a
good person but in the grand scheme of
things whereas he's deferring that title
to the almighty God so so this is where
we would disagree because right
obviously here he doesn't say that he's
not good he doesn't deny being good he
doesn't say he's not good he doesn't say
do not call me good he just asks the
question why do you call me good only
God is good right there's only one good
and that's God alone if Jesus is good
right in the great SC uh you know grand
scheme of things then Jesus Is God there
only God is morally perfect right as
human beings we all sin angels are even
uh imperfect but there's only one who is
perfect and that's God so Jesus asking
the Young Ruler the question why do you
call me good is similar to his
thought-provoking questions that he asks
anyone that he's engaging with and the
man didn't understand what he was saying
because what he's saying is it implies
that Jesus is God and the man didn't
understand what he was saying so this is
a common response Christians gives
that's a rhetorical question that what
what the Jesus wants to do is to make
the young man reflect who he really is
by your explanation however note
something he doesn't say do you know why
you call me good no that by necessity by
English grammar that would then
necessitate that then the question would
be posed as to why you know why you're
calling me good then your explanation
would make semantic sense however the
point Remains by him deferring the title
exclusively giving that to God Alone
secondly in regards to this rhetorical
response you've made when Jesus gives
that young man the advice he does not go
away concluding oh now I get it you're
God Almighty so the rhetorical nature of
your response makes no sense whatsoever
so within the context notice something
in verse 20 this is the verse that
Christians need to reflect upon in verse
20 he drops the title good and simply
calls Jesus teacher hence he's
understood look look what he's
understood that when I called him good
teacher Jesus pounced on me for calling
him good teacher and when he redresses
Jesus he simply calls him teacher in
verse 20 hence he has understood now a
further substantiation are you going to
can I can I jump in here yeah but let me
just because you because I listen on to
what you said in terms of rhetoric yeah
but you're you're you're saying a lot
though you got to let me jump in at some
point okay good I appreciate it so it's
it's not simply just a uh you're now
turning into a grammatical problem as if
uh yeah that's what you're saying as if
Jesus saying why do you call me good
does not make sense grammatically in him
asking a thought-provoking question
whether he says do you know why you call
me good or whether he says why do you
call me good both grammatically work
with the question it doesn't matter how
how he said it him saying why do you
call me good it's still a
thought-provoking question it's hold on
let me let me continue because he then
continues as you like you you're talking
about the context he continues to go on
and says tells him to sell all his
things and sell all all his possessions
and come follow him for his eternal life
that there's one thing that he lacks and
he has to follow Jesus for his eternal
life notice how this is also an
expression of Jesus showing that he is
the one who is good and he is the one
who is the way for his his eternal life
if he's if he's following all the
Commandments he said he's kept all the
Commandments from the beginning right
love your love your mother and father
don't lie don't cheat don't steal y y y
right but then he says Jesus says
there's one thing that you lack in all
of the Comm I want to ask you this
Mustafa in all of The Commandments that
he was keeping and Jesus says there's
one that he lacks sell your possessions
then come follow me what is what
commandment is that tied to yeah so in
essence what he's saying within the
Preamble of Mark 10:17 is that what he's
actually telling him after rebuking him
for calling him good so let me just deal
with that point before I address this
singular point that you made So within
the context you're saying that
grammatically it doesn't make a
difference but it does because in
Matthew 19: 16-1 19 of the same account
because Mark is the First Gospel for
every want attention when Matthew reads
the same account Matthew rearranges the
word which he's got such a problem
sitting thinking why is Jesus saying
that only God is good alone so he then
says in Matthew 19: 16 why do you ask me
about what is good so he changes the
statement into a question about
generically what is good that's Matthew
chapter 19: 16 to 19 which changes the
context of what Mark is saying in Mark
10:1 17 now to sub iate your point about
come and follow me yes because in
because it's not just enough notice the
question is what Mis Li you to get
eternal life so the eternal life is not
just sufficient to keeping the
Commandments and doing good deeds you
have to go over and go like you
Christians have come over from the US
why because you think that you want to
get close to Jesus and therefore you
want to do extra work to get to obtain
that eternal life will you be guaranteed
so Christ is saying in that context come
and follow me what commandment is that
tied to so the Commandment just simply
tied to the fact that he says here thou
Israel your lord God the Lord is one
boom so if the Commandment is love the
Lord your God with all your heart mind
and soul and you shall not go you know
worship any other gods put nothing
before me no other Idols right this man
obviously had his possessions as his
most adored thing above God and so in
order for him to obey that commandment
correctly he had to then go give it up
for Jesus no no let me explain what he
had to do in this context because the
riches are an obstacle just imagine he's
obstacle to work I'll explain to you
just imagine he's going around following
Jesus what's that what does that follow
mean it simply means going forth and
spreading the message to Jesus amongst
the Jews what does he say that I'll
explain to you because when he says
follow me what does that mean are you
going to literally just walk behind
Jesus at every juncture no it literally
means follow me because of the task that
I'm setting forth for the other people
the disciples to go forth to prize to
the L of the House of Israel say that
well within the because follow me what
does follow me we're in the context what
does follow me beautiful it means so
when you follow Jesus you believe who he
is and you obey his word you love him
you keep his Commandments one of The
Commandments is to believe that he is
the Son of God who came down to give us
life as a ransom for many you follow
Jesus in believing yeah that's exactly
we're still in Mark we're still in Mark
10 but what I'm saying to you to negate
that particular Point what the term Son
of God are you Christian people here
aware which is the sad Paradox of
History that the term Son of God is
defined in Matthew 5:9 it says the
following yes it says the following
blessed are the peacemakers for they too
will be called the sons of God the term
sons of God ladies and gentlemen is a
ubiquitous title used for those who
represent God and we see this further
alluded to other individuals like in
Luke 3:38 Adam is referred to as the Son
of God we look at Exodus 4:22 Jacob is
referred to as a Son of God and
furthermore of significant changing no
no because you because I I like where
this is going I'm okay you're the one
who defin Son of God I just going to
make it clear to everyone the Christian
a in particular that what does Son of
God mean so in John 10:33 Jesus says is
it not written in your scriptures that
you you mind if I snap this on you
yeah so in John chap 10:33 jesuses does
he say to those Jews those obstinate
Jews who not written in your scriptures
that you too are Gods so all it means
one who is referred to as a Son of God
is referred to as one who represent
present God now going back to the point
of Mark can I respond to that okay I
appreciate it so you're now so now
you're trying to generalize sons of God
which then if you acknowledge that God
has sons in this sense then what you
have on your tent three men one message
you have just refuted that and and now
rejected that because according to Moses
according to two of those men they have
one message that God has sons in many
senses according to one of those men God
Allah doesn't have any sons has he's a
father to no one in any sense I hope you
you agree okay good so you're agreeing
with that so then what you're saying
shows that Moses and Jesus as you're
quoting the Bible over there Deuteronomy
and Mark uh ironically both in Mark and
in in Deuteronomy both two of those men
on your tent disagree with the message
of Muhammad so you just threw Muhammad
under the bus and showed how terminology
I'm not going to okay for forgive me so
you you just refuted Muhammad I'll say
you refuted m Muhammad and showing that
it's not 3 one message is two men one
message against a man who's against
their message but talking about the sons
now you you understand in Mark for
example you are you familiar with the
story of The Vineyard Jesus parable with
the vineyard right okay how and you and
who's the vine who's the owner of the
vineyard in the in the parable yes it's
it's God right and the one his servants
that he sends are the prophets and then
finally it says then I will send my son
who I love they respect him who's the
son in that yeah so the son in this
context is referred to again as Christ
but the term son in itself but the term
sun in itself listen gentlemen this is
not why AR why what I wanted to just
sorry I wanted to substantiate this why
AR why did Jesus differentiate himself
from the prophets by calling them the
Servants of the vineyard owner while he
calls himself the Beloved son who is the
heir The Heir and inheritor of the
vineyard owner yeah so in terms of this
title son prophet of God um Messiah
these are all interchangeable titles so
this is why you get other people who are
referred to as sons of God you got other
people who are referred to as Messiah
you got other people who are refer to as
saviors so these are not titles just
stick summarily to Jesus Christ they are
ubiquitous titles for those who
represent God hence you get these terms
now what he's saying makes no say
Hebrews in chapter one of Hebrews it
makes mention that in terms of the
angels that Jesus was even higher than
the Angels so it makes no sense within
the context to say if Jesus is higher
than the which God by default would be
higher so in this particular context in
reference to what you've said if he's
referring to as a son it's just one who
represents reference what yeah I'm just
giv you that no no how how does Hebrews
1 about the Angels relate to the parable
of how the son is different from the
prophets how's that relate yeah because
what it says in Hebrews chapter 1 is
essentially speaking that the Angels God
God has made the Angels but Christ is
even higher than the Angels so it makes
no sense within the context of the
chapter that you would then say such a
things yes which is already God's by
default that Christ would be higher than
the Angels because that would already be
given wait wait I I don't understand
there correlation though how how is
Christ being higher than the Angels
which you're right he is how is that
correlating to how Jesus separates
himself from the prophets as the
Servants of God while he's the son of
God how does that correlate yeah but
these are still titles which are
interchangeable you can use either or
titles why does he make a distinction
between himself between him and it's
irrelevant because the term listen the
term Son of God literally means one who
represents God
these are
interchangeable so explain to me why in
Luke 338 it's Adam the Son of God so
okay because he's the first he's the
first human created by God so he so he
is the Son of God in the sense that he
is God's creation right so look that's
your definition well in the no in the
Bible it gives you different different
context in which God has a son and which
who's the son of God Adam being God's
creation he's he's uh you know the the
one Jesus creation it as well no he's
not well he's not first born of creation
well no that that means that he's above
creation that means preeminence it says
he's the first born of the dead too was
that was he the first one to die yeah no
that means that okay wa wait no no stop
stop please when you say that he's the
firstborn the firstborn of creation you
keep reading it says because by him all
things were created in heaven on Earth
visible invisible Thrones dominions
principalities rulers all things were
created through him and for him and he
is before all things and in him all
things consist and he is the firstborn
of the dead so so that he of the let me
finish it so that his preeminence is
shown above everything so all of that
firstborn is preeminence it's not always
the first little thing yeah well so in
the context of the verse that you've
cited when it says all things came
through him that by definition shows
he's not the source in one Corin listen
guys in one Corinth how is that let me
explain to you in one and I'll Define
the term First Corinthians 86 yes 1
Corinthians 8: 1-6 Paul says the
following uh For unto us there is one
God the father from whom all things come
meaning the source and one Lord Jesus
Christ through whom all things came
meaning he's the passive conduit okay
well let me explain because I'm
answering your question directly in
correlation because I'm giving a
definition for the audience to
understand as well so when all things
I'm not switching topics what I'm trying
to show to you based upon the C citation
you made from 1 Clans 15 that when it
comes to this that yes I quoted it but
you substantiated it so I'm giving you
an understanding when you say all things
are made through him this must make him
God Almighty but
no I didn't say that you said you're the
one who's citing that as evidence as
well no I didn't I never know brother
you you're the one okay let me get it
straight so you don't believe one
Colossians Jesus Is God it's not one
Colossians it's just Colossians but yes
it does show that Jesus is Creator along
with the father however but hold on you
said that I contradicted yourself no
listen Mustafa you said said that I
brought this up as a point I didn't
bring this up I only answered you
because you went to Colossians 1 to try
to say that Jesus is also created
because it says he's the firstborn of
all creation I corrected you and gave
you the context of of Colossians 1 to
show you how actually it shows that
Jesus is God and creator of everything
along with the father but it but then
then what happened then when he says all
things were created by means of him and
through him by definition the Greek word
there is called Dia now the means by the
means of so God creates all the universe
by the means of Jesus as the passive
conduit so that let me let let me finish
beautiful preaching the go I'm not
preaching the gospel because this is
this is what you call without even
realizing there's a distinction between
when something comes from something and
something comes through something we all
understand we're trar I know but that's
the tragedy of the matter so when it com
yeah let me let me substantiate so when
it come when something is from something
he is the SCE okay when something is
through something he is that conduit
like Jesus says in um uh John 14: six I
am the way the truth and life no man
come through to the father but by
through me so you have to get through um
uh to God right so what is the relevant
point I don't want this to become I want
people to focus summarily so when one 8
ver 4-6 which is
from so even he distinguishes in 1
Corinthians 86 that who is God the
father and the Lord Jesus Christ the
word
cuos the veres before Paul says there
are many
gods I know because what I'm trying to
do I want people to reflect because you
made the point by substantiating in one
closing 15 because all let's focus on
one thing though okay so the one thing
that let's at least Focus cuz you're
like you're chopping up going everywhere
I'm not chopping I'm just trying to
substantiate the point I got you but
let's stay focus okay cuz you have a lot
that you want to say let's stay focused
so let's deal with um
let's deal with the creation part okay
you said that Colossians proves that
Jesus is created okay when it says that
he's the firstborn of all creation for
by him all things were created by means
of the Greek word by means of that no it
is by by him and through and for it says
all of those things let me ask you this
okay by means of okay okay I got I got
worries have you to the differ Len in
the I'll go with you yeah that means by
but by the means of that's that's
a what you're trying to do is you're
trying to use the New World Translation
cuz you like to hang Hing on Jehovah's
Witnesses but it doesn't help you
Jehovah's Witness you got still AR go to
the Bible
hub.net stat on there by means of the
must but here's my question here's my
question this my question cut me Offa
you're cutting me off though give me
I'll give you full 3 minutes to I don't
need three minutes I don't need want to
say to you now listen need minutes a
matter
so now we're just going to get in a
shouting match doesn't want you to hear
what I'm saying that's the question you
speak listen to so no so I don't need 3
minutes I'm asking you a direct question
okay cuz you're trying to run from this
I'm not running okay good so when you
admit that it says that that all things
the universe right the world it
says the oh so ages what does ages mean
what does ages mean it means from the
time so all time doesn't say from the
unit why you the word time out so J so
it's through Jesus that time was created
correct no not through Jesus no n hang
where you going where are you walking
away to oh my word you don't even know
what you're talking about oh my God what
are we doing here okay you you just said
that ages means time and you just said
that by means of Jesus ages ages means
past it doesn't but what you're trying
to do is to try to show he was at the
beginning of time that's what you just
said now you stuck Through the Ages okay
what does ages mean from the time that
he came into existence wait wait okay
time out all right let's let's focus on
that it says by let's go with you yeah
yeah go by means of him yes all things
were created what are the all things so
that means the heaven that that's not
the heavens and the Earth you know what
this is about it's not the heavens and
the Earth you know what this is the
heavens and the Earth this like the you
know what this is about this is about
the new creation the new heaven the new
the new dominions the found the found
found it's not speaking about the
heavens and the Earth this is the new
creation the new creation
yes let me finish so what he said people
you know within the shouting we can't
really get then what is happening here
so he said that Jesus is um the first
born of creation okay this was your
point now I said to you he's the first
born from the dead how can God die one
one um Timothy changing the argument I'm
not changing no
argum this is you because you know
because you know you areu
so this when it refers to the first born
according to James DG dun a very eminent
New Testament scholar he's written a
book called the um the evidence for
Jesus he States explicitly that um this
is in reference to the the uh the New
Creation in terms of when he rises again
the dominions and the and the
foundations it's not speaking about the
he the creation of the heavens because
in Mark's gospel it says that God
created the heavens and the earth when
Jesus says that it doesn't say that he
created the heavens and the Earth so
that's distinguishing gospel says Jesus
Is God no no listen guys so let me just
wrap I'm going to give you a so first of
all notice he said something in in one
closing 15 but the term there is by by
him all things were made so I then
corrected him and later you can check it
out he's got it he accepts by means of
so when you are the by the means of
something you are not the source or you
it's not from you that everything
derives that's the first point so I
educated him on the Greek word they
called you sure did but you never knew
and then afterwards you accepted it by
the means love
Lear so these are I mean the CH The
champ is not here yet so when he comes
he'll go on another level but let me
just say to so just to continue further
um so that can I tou on that I'm was
going to finish off now but I just want
to summarize very quickly so the by so
by him means by the means of not by him
so and it's through him meaning he's the
passive conduit like in two in two pH
going on again I'm not because I'm
substantiating my
point look the audience get it it's by
means of Jesus yeah but so then I'm
going substantiate further to hammer
that point home you're just making
another what I'm trying to do is to show
as my evidence it's by the means of like
for
example I'm going to keep silent I'm
going to keep silent in 2 philippians: 6
to1 making another point it's to
substantiate you you tell me let you
finish you're about to wrap up I sit
here quiet and then you make another
point no no because it's to substantiate
the point so you guys already done we
everything is everything made by Jesus
or is he by the means of so then when
you look at the when you look at the yes
we go with by the means that's a big
difference it's really a huge difference
I'm going show you how it's I'm show you
how it's not hang on let me substantiate
the point what you just did all things
all things come by him you're then
implying that he is the source
of means you can yes okay thank you so
you said that all things is not all
things is that correct um all things
meaning that the heavens and the Earth
the new heavens and wait does it okay
let me ask
you question you just did it does it say
does it say that he by mean by means of
him all new things were created or does
it say by means of him all things were
created which one yes all is not
mentioned in the generic sense because
sometimes all can be just for example in
the Old Testament there's a reference
where people are referred to as they all
came and did God's work but there was
only a few select Jews who came to do
God's work so what it says within the
context all is not always one second
I'll come there no no you got to
substantiate it you like substanti
to bring it up don't talk about you
can't make upir but you can't remember
from every single verse I remember as
much as possible if you're going to
bring up something in this conversation
you got to have it that's fine but you
would be familiar with this
understanding that the word all does not
have to be taken in a literal sense let
me give me an example where all creation
doesn't mean all creation okay I'll
bring that for you well it's not going
around Circle you're not dealing with
the argument I am dealing with the ARG
so when it says all things does it say
all no no Mustafa does it say new things
or all things so when it says that he is
the new creat means in terms of does it
say new or does it say all Mustafa yeah
but all all is irrelevant to this point
all I want to know is if it says all or
does it say all new okay so even if it's
listen it's in let me be patient let me
exp so in that definition in one
Colossians chapter 15 stop saying one
Colossians just coloss okay one
Colossians 15 it very very clearly says
that all things were made by the means
of him okay and through that all things
or is that some things that's all I want
to know is within the context of the new
creation wait okay got
the I got I got you I got beautiful so
where ref I got you I got you I where in
Colossians 1 does it mention New
Creation it's mentioned within the
within the context where show me the
verse so it says that that it makes
reference be reference to the New
Foundations and the new dominions okay
good new new dominions let's have a look
at this he said he said that the verse
in Colossians 1 is in context of new
creation because actually mentions the
new creation it actually mentions new
dominions new principalities I got you I
got you it's not in reference to the
from the beginning all right God created
everything okay got you let's let's see
here now watch this ladies and gentlemen
when we pull this up let's see if he's
telling the truth so Colossians one okay
all right all right all right verse 15
this is what it says he is the image of
the invisible God the firstborn of all
maybe that's all new creation right not
all creation he's the firstborn of all
new creation yes okay so not all
creation not from the Mark's gospel he
said God created the heavens and the
Earth but in Mark's gospel it says that
God created the heav Earth say I created
the create the don't don't don't move
away now well the father says that Jesus
created the new the heavens and the
Earth so it looks like the father no it
doesn't say that in yeah in Hebrews hold
on let me say in Hebrews 1 the father
says that Jesus is the Lord who created
all things things by his
hands Hebrews
1 oh man I'm quoting it Hebrews chapter
1 ver 10 look look I got you I got you
Hebrew 1 ver I'm very familiar with this
going be it says this is what the father
says to the son you Lord laid the
foundations of the earth and the heavens
are the work of your hands wow but
didn't Jesus say in Mark that the that
the father is the Lord who created the
heavens and the Earth so it looks like
it looks like both the father and the
son glorify each other as the source of
all creation that's called biblical
literacy that's how you know how to read
right you must read you must wait let me
finish this cuz I don't want us to get
away from it you know what I'm saying so
look Hebrews 1 he said and mentiones New
Creation let's see that's in Colossians
1 Colossians 1 yeah don't T Hebrews one
I didn't say that well if I said I
misspoke my bad all right um okay so
he's the image of the invisible God the
firstborn of all creation for by him or
with him by means of him all things were
created not all new things all things
were created now it gives us in detail
cuz he said it doesn't create the the
Heaven and the Earth let's see what he
created what what what are all things um
that are in
heaven wait you're not supposed to say
that Paul you're supposed to say the new
heaven Paul created all things that are
in heaven and he didn't say he said not
the new he said not Earth and and that
are une Earth visible and
invisible whether Thrones or dominions
principalities or Powers watch this all
things were created through him and for
him where here well okay hold on and he
is before all things and in him all
things hold together without him
creation falls apart that's in Jesus so
how is he not where does he mention New
Creation here I I need to see where it
mentions ref New Creation ref it refers
to principalities and dominions does it
mention new principalities yes it does
because hang on within the context this
is referencing that he's the first born
from creation that that one minute let
me finish the point so by necessity God
is not first born does that make sense
he is God he is God is firstborn yes he
is almighty God hang on one minute
almighty God who's Immortal who has got
no beginning no who has got No Beginning
No End yet you are saying Jesus is the
first born yeah absolutely I'm going to
show you your ignorance here the reason
why you're surprised by that is because
you don't know the Bible for examp yeah
for okay you know the Bible okay so
that's why you want to you don't want to
good how many how many brothers did
David have I don't know how many
brothers that's not consequential to I'm
going to show you how it's consequential
that's not okay was David the oldest
middle or youngest I don't know you
don't know I'm going to help you that's
irrelevant to the point there was eight
of I'm going to tell you I'm show you
there was eight of them there was eight
of them David was the youngest now in
Psalm 89 verse 27 God says about David
you are my first
born huh wait hold on a second David's
the youngest so how is it that David
could be the firstborn Mustafa precisely
good point that's that shows that the
Bible is a bundle of contradiction in
Exodus in Exodus 4:22 Israel or Jacob is
referred to as the first born okay so
what this is what this is within the
context that they are all over the place
in terms of is is Jacob the firstborn or
is it David is the firstborn make your
mind up or is it Jesus is the first born
it's easy look Mustafa if you knew the
Bible you would you wouldn't even be
making this mistake this is going to be
embarrassing it's not embarrassing
you're the one embarrassed by the means
you accept so this is what it means let
let me finish let me finish so this is
what it means firstborn is a title of
preeminence Supremacy so yes God is
first born because he's Supreme over all
creation duh so when Jesus is called the
firstborn of all creation he's the
Supreme one of all creation it just
makes that's him adding into it you know
what I'm saying that's him adding his
his premeditating understanding okay
definition according to James DG joh
don't argue with me top new does it say
new do he's making reference that's in
terms of the new creation the new
principalities the New Foundations is
when he returns hence hence it says he's
the first born you see from the dead
doesn't it say let me explain to you
when they say he's the first born from
the dead what does that tell you that
means that on on his return when he has
yeah within the context he's telling you
where because you know why because he's
telling you the new the principalities
say new why you keep throwing new
because look I'm going to give you my
phone show me the word new okay so when
you're when your first no no here sorry
don't worry don't worry about the melow
drama if when you're talking about the F
the term first born by necessity is
understood to be in Revelation he's
referred to be the first born from the
dead I think I was reading it yesterday
in Revelation chapter it's also it's
also right here in Colossians it's okay
right so when you're first born from the
dead so what does this mean then it
means you're preeminent over those who
raised from the dead one minute let me
speak now okay so when you're the first
born from the dead that necessitates on
his return so it's substant listen to me
it substantiates my point so when you
the firstborn from the dead that means
when you have you've come back when he
will come back so that's when he will be
ruling that's when he will be ruling
according to the new can you please
connect the dots we're all confused I
don't know why you should be it's
explanatory within the
context within the context in Revelation
chap 1 and in Revelation 5 it makes
mention that he's the first born from
the dead let let me finish let me finish
please I can't see the word new here bro
but it's in ref the context determines
that is determining it the passage
because listen this is this guy around
in circles listen when you are when you
are dead when you are when you have died
when you're the first born from the dead
what which Jesus is according to
Christians you all believe that don't
you excellent so by definition if he's
the firstborn from the dead in this
particular context it's referring to the
new dominions the new hang on let me the
new dominions the new um uh
principalities what are those
principalities so when he comes and
rules upon um upon Mankind and judges
according to what God has revealed to
him so it's in that context it's making
reference to and why am I saying that
which you been going around too many
circles is that when this is the
definition in Revelation is that he's
the first born from the dead he then
comes and then he's then he has that new
creation that that who is that new
creation those who will follow him those
who he will have the principalities and
the dominions that he will rule upon
because we know Jesus did not rule at
the time that he was there he only ruled
at this when he returns So within the
context of this and this is not me
saying it James DG dun one of the
greatest New Testament Scholars of the
20th century okay I would like to see
that quote from JG dun that says exactly
what you said so this is where we get I
guess we can end it cuz you say it's
going in circles I'll say my point you
just said yours yeah good point um guys
uh you guys can see what what it does
what happens to you when you don't read
the Bible um you see what happens to you
when you can't read context and you see
what happens to you when you're you know
you get a little tooe of yourself and
you start start saying things that
doesn't end up in the Bible this is why
you get embarrassed on camera when you
say things that you can't prove you just
can't prove it don't say oh it's talking
about oh it's New Creation you no notice
how first of all guys I wasn't even the
one that brought this up he came here he
had the nerve to come to Colossians 1 to
try to prove that Jesus wasn't God when
it calls him
Creator Earth him but now not it's not
it's not all of creation it's talking
about the ages what does ages mean
Mustafa times oh so Jesus created the
times he so all of time came into
existence through Jesus so even did say
for example hey did I interrupt your
summary this m let me cook man let me
cook let me cook goodness so he came
here and it shows brother how you
butchered your position by coming to a
to a verse that shows that Jesus is
divine Jesus is Creator and Jesus is Su
Supreme Over All of creation there isn't
even a question about it in this verse
you got yourself in trouble now how did
we get here though we got here because
he wanted to run away from how Jesus
distinguishes himself from the prophets
he tried to say that Son of God is just
a general term that anybody is a Son of
God which in a in some sense he actually
does have a case that Son of God there's
many senses that you can be sons of God
Ain angs are sons of God Adam was a Son
of God prophets are sons of God Kings of
Israel are sons of God Israel the nation
are sons of God Sons by the tongu but
there's something that Jesus says he
says that God sent his son into the
world his only
son his only son that you should that
the world should be saved through him
wait a second why does Jesus say he's
the unique son the only son when he has
many why does Jesus make a distinction
which he answer by the way in Mark 12
where Jesus says that God sent His
prophets they killed his prophets they
murdered His prophets they disrespected
His prophets then the owner says you
know what there's one more I'm going to
send my son wait Jesus We're All Sons
you're just a prophet like them you're
all
Sons why is it that you're making this
distinction because there is a a true
distinction that Jesus is the son of God
in the sense that he shares the same
Divine Essence as God he is the son of
the father eternally begotten from the
father's Essence full of grace and truth
which is why there's none like him which
is why he's the unique Son of God who
came into the world he's different from
the rest there ain't nobody like him not
Moses not Abraham not Muhammad only
Jesus that's how we got here so are you
finished let me finish up let me just
you did I have I didn't make a summary
that's a conclusive summary let me make
a summary as well okay so notice
everybody what did we establish over
here when he cited one Colossians 15
stop saying one Colossians just
difference okay one col 15 what did he
say he said that everything was made by
Jesus and for Jesus and through Jesus so
I then said to him and he admitted
afterwards it's all been recorded I said
the Greek word there is Dia which means
by the means of
is a big distinction but it's not he is
the he's the source so then he
afterwards what did he say he said yeah
by the means of he didn't say no by him
it's a big difference but if you're
doing something through someone or if
you're doing something by yourself that
you would can then make that claim so he
exceeded that point without even
realizing and we're very fortunate that
without one minute and we're very
fortunate this has been recorded for
everybody's attention for the genuine
people second point when we went through
one coluans 15 which I brought up
initially to substantiate a particular
point it was to show that when Jesus
returns because it says he will be the
first born from the dead and our cited
Revelation which he accepted he accepted
in Revelation he's referred to as the
first born from the dead so it's in this
context that when he returns and he will
be um the ruler over the principalities
and the foundations and the this new
Earth which will be presented to him
what is this new Earth this new Earth is
when he returns it's not because in
Mark's gospel he says that um Mark I
think it's Mark chapter 3 when he says
that um God created the heavens and the
Earth he didn't say and I created the
heavens and the Earth so that
distinguishes between the two and the
other point that he made and I'll wrap
it up very quickly the term Son of God
now he's making a um a pre-assumption
that the term Son of God necessitates
that Christ is a distinct and unique Son
of God in a way which is not the case as
you would find in the normal context of
things I cited Luke 3:38 where Adam too
is referred to as the Son of God in in
in Exodus 4:22 Jacob is also referred to
as the Son of God so the Son of God is
defined in Matthew 5:9 it says blessed
are the peacemakers for they too will be
known as the sons of God so the term
sons of God is a ubiquitous title for
those who represent God then he cited
the term Son of God in John 3:16 for God
soever loved the word that he gave his
only begotten son okay let's deal with
that the term there is used is Jess
which is unique and we know Jesus hang
on no it's not Mon it's not in no it's
let me explain to you let me explain to
you so
fin
mymm I kept quiet while she was speaking
so anyway so the point now we we got to
understand is yes he's unique in the
sense that he was born of um of a virgin
birth but it doesn't necessitate that
he's unique in terms of being a Son of
God me a literal Son of God because I've
given you the definition blessed are the
peacemakers for they too will be called
the sons of God so whoever does God's
work is refer to the Son of God very
last point it came back to Mark 1017
which is where the conversation started
initially so when the young young man if
for example all of us are over here if I
was to say Avery is the only person from
the United States that by default would
exclude us so when Jesus says in Mark
10:17 why do you call me good there's no
one good except for God Alone he's
excluding that title to himself by just
English grammar look he's he's it's a
deference of title to God alone and to
substantiate the point 30 seconds of
Lama playe in which um he says in in
verse 20 the young man then says to him
teacher I've kept these Commandments
since I was appoint what does this mean
that means to show that he's understood
whoa Jesus told me off for calling him
good teacher so in verse 20 when I
redress Jesus I simply call him teacher
hence he has understood that this is a
title exclusively for God Alone wrapped
up beautifully and 10 seconds John 173
for this is eternal life Jesus is the
formula that he may know you as the only
true God and whom you have sent the the
apostos Jesus Christ go to the Bible
hub.net John 17:3 is that the father
he's referred to as a messenger sent by
God is that the father God is the only
true God is Father yes so Allah so he so
he any we can do I know you you like to
speak about the term father just so I
don't want to so okay guys problem so we
finished we finished the conversation
over here a enjoyable conversation so I
hope everybody is understood among so
amongst all of the um
man oh man
so no shaking of hands um but man what a
good discussion I love that he came out
and actually had the guts to talk the
rest of the guys didn't they didn't have
the guts to talk but he came we had to
force him to come and have a to bait him
in a conversation and uh now we just saw
the hypocrisy of Islam Islam is peace
and love but they can't even Shake our
hands of the of the disbeliever so but
it's all good man were you guys blessed
by the
conversation amen amen amen that's me
that's right Christ is King
y'all Christ is King y'all that's right
yes you Bo that's right all right where
we going next oh my God logic
oh